[Music]
do you have an idea for a new product
service or business but need training
and guidance to bring it to life my name
is Chuck Easley and I'm an associate
professor in the department of
management science and engineering at
Stanford University we are inviting
teams across Thailand in Southeast Asia
to apply to participate in a free
learning experience through an online
entrepreneurship boot camp where over
eleven weeks you and your team will
learn valuable entrepreneurial
frameworks that I and my colleagues
teach and our entrepreneurship courses
at Stanford participants who complete
all of the work will receive a statement
of accomplishment and some teams will
also be selected to connect with a
curated group of industry mentors as
part of their learning journey this boot
camp is part of a unique research
project on entrepreneurship training
models being conducted as part of the
Stanford Thailand research consortium
through the experience you will complete
assignments conduct multiple rounds of
customer research and prototype and test
your ideas and by the end your team will
have a well honed pitch a prototype and
a business model to use to engage
partners and possible funding following
the bootcamp dozens of teams have
already participated in this interactive
experience working on ideas and ventures
in the areas of artificial intelligence
blockchain agriculture as well as
software products and services I invite
you now to sign up and apply to join our
next cohort of teams learning together
to take their ideas and ventures to the
next level
you
[Music]